uh in december we asked you to submit
the nominations for remarkable women in
your life and based on your submissions
we've picked four top choices of
remarkable women here in the valley and
this morning we're going to introduce
you to yusuf koich she's all about
lifting up others creating joy by
helping the community and paying it
forward
her message of kindness comes all the
way from kenya i had to fetch water from
the river
we washed we had no running water no
electricity or anything like that but
there was so much love in our home a
love that inspired yuselakowicz and
pushed her to pursue her dream of coming
to the united states eventually
graduating from unlv my village my
community came together and made sure
that i
finished high school i stand here today
and i'm getting emotional right now but
i stand here today because of generosity
of a lot of people and coeds made it her
life's work to pay it forward i was
given a chance a chance that she now
offers to other young women for me i
wanted to to go back and
look at girls like myself and say
you can have your dreams and your
ambitions and they're valid she recently
created the give me a chance foundation
to inspire others and help them make
their dreams come true we've educated a
few girls but we're in the process of
really just building it and making sure
that i can go back home
and select you know
growth that come from
very poor backgrounds but it doesn't
stop there as koich knows being an
immigrant can be challenging on so many
levels that's why she helped create the
african diaspora of las vegas when i
went to college there's only four of us
here now there's a whole african
community we have people connecting we
have business people that have
businesses that are able to connect
culturally right like
and also showcase who we are as a people
to the las vegas community that we call
home and it's homes the so-called
american dream of home ownership that
pushes coach in her day job as a senior
loan officer to work tirelessly to help
others having a home brings stability to
the family which is why she also spends
time feeding the homeless and opening
her home to those in need my joy comes
with people by helping people a wife
mother of two teenage boys career woman
and philanthropist this sometimes you
don't have enough hours i wish i had 28
hours a day here 9 000 miles away from
her birthplace she's made a home in
southern nevada sharing kindness with
everyone she meets there's a lot of good
people in vegas
we'll continue sharing more remarkable
women every tuesday this month 8 news
now will reveal the winner in april and
then he'll be in the running for the
next r woman of the year for the company
we love that that story is amazing she's
an amazing woman really truly
inspirational